all right ron thanks for that i was just
finishing off auntie shells pie over
there that's a sweet potato pie
that was some good pie random to have
pie a week after thanksgiving right but
it really it hit the spot
you know rocky has pulled through for us
there's nothing wrong with pie season
year-round yes right that's a good point
you know it's a great pie it's key lime
oh yeah it's dinner time it's dinner
time right i'm just going to say you
guys are talking about everybody's
watching us right now for dinner let's
talk about the forecast it's going to
work
no because it does get us back on track
a little cooler today ted just a little
bit cooler and if you look at the screen
there the high roller looks like pie
sorry
it's just that time all right clear
skies right now actually some clouds
overhead but the skies are going to
clear overnight 69 degrees denise was
right 69 our high today that was it
because yesterday remember our high was
75 degrees and that actually uh broke a
set of new records 60 our average 78 is
the record that was set back in 1940 so
nowhere near that record and i think
we're going to be out of record
territory all the way through the rest
of this week and definitely out of
regulatory territory for
next week as well currently 59 for
centenni hills along with summerlin and
we're at 66 for downtown double six is
for you also for the east side sunrise
manor 63 green valley new neighborhoods
here to show you rhodes ranch spanish
trails you guys are 58 degrees 58 also
for seven hills and also silverado ranch
outside of town 59 for prom 56 mesquite
68 for laughlin right now radar network
showing clear skies and it's going to
remain that way as far as the radar
network goes no echoes coming back on
the radar clear from any rainfall but
that could change though by the time we
get to early on next week there's the
low off the coast here that's the one
that's actually providing all the cloud
cover that we're seeing outside right
now that's going to clear as far as the
shower chances go we're going to up them
up just a little bit on monday as that
low scoots off south that high breaks
down and then we'll have several
disturbances come down look at this this
is for monday night slight chances could
be returning that means more mountain
snow too we need it right and then
another chance could be returning look
at this later on in the work week next
week so we have several opportunities
for shower chances due to several
disturbances that will be rolling on in
through the region cooler temperatures
expected next week too along with this
all right we told you we'd track those
winds for you it'll start to get breezy
monday night breezy on tuesday and
another
round of wins on thursday next week from
that other system that will move its way
in so right now i just got to deal with
clouds for tonight those clouds will
still be around temperatures will be
cool in those mid 50s nothing chilly
though because the clouds give us a
little blanket of warmth outside that's
what we're seeing outside right now the
high tomorrow 70 degrees and we are back
to sunshine tomorrow but still
unseasonably warm because look at this
is where we should be tomorrow 59
degrees we're looking at 70 and we're
going to be staying near the low 70's as
we get through your weekend good looking
weekend then next week there's those
changes going to feel more like fall for
sure shower chances breezy winds and
even high 50s on friday denise already
all right ted will